I'm in Crystal Palace Park, in south London,
and there are dinosaurs.
Models of dinosaurs, anyway.
And inaccurate models at that:
but that's because they're
more than 150 years old.
These were the first ever lifesize models
of extinct creatures,
built for the gardens
of the enormous Crystal Palace
that used to stand
on top of that hill over there.
They were made by the wonderfully-named
Benjamin Waterhouse Hawkins,
we now know that they are utterly wrong
in many significant ways,
but at the time they were a marvel:
look at what once walked the earth!
Now, in England, there's a list of buildings
that have special protection under the law.
Buildings on that list are called...
Listed Buildings.
Because they're on the list.
Of buildings.
And this country's full of them: Historic
England,
the not-quite-government organisation
that manages the list,
says there's about
half a million buildings on it.
Most of those are only Grade 2 listed,
which means they've got to be
kept mostly intact,
and any changes need
a really good reason behind them,
but more than 10,000 places
are Grade 1 listed,
which means they must be preserved.
Pretty much anything that was built more than 200 years ago and is still standing is on the list,
but there are some more modern things too...
including these dinosaurs.
Yep. Grade 1 listed dinosaurs.
Can't be changed, moved, or demolished,
have to kept in good condition.
And they can't be updated to reflect what
modern palaeontologists know,
because that would involve changing them,
and destroying not a dinosaur display --
but a display about what we
once thought dinosaurs looked like,
something that's notable not
because of what it represents in itself,
but because of the history in the sculptures.
These dinosaurs must, by law,
remain inaccurate,
because the story they tell
isn't about prehistoric times...
it's about science, just 150 years ago.
I've done a video with Minute Earth about
Null Island,
the busiest place that doesn't exist.
You can check go it out on their channel.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name
here!]